okay let's talk about what everybody's
talking about Trump fired off some
missiles everyone seems to be very
jazzed about this on TV in the last 24
hours
let me add some facts to it first of all
I'd like to mention that he's really
sliding on the fact that on Monday of
this week the Trump administration told
Assad you know what we don't really care
what you do whether you stay whether you
go so maybe that emboldened him to do
this on Wednesday that's number one
also the Syrian regime has dropped
twelve thousand nine hundred and fifty
eight barrel bombs just last year I
guess chemicals are worse and they
certainly are potentially worse but I
guess if you die you die and the us in
2016 drop twelve thousand one hundred
ninety two Bob's bombs of our own and
Syria on the other side of the war
because now we're bombing both sides of
a war what happened that we got to wipe
out Isis first well you just say I will
I look I would love to respond to that
it is a misconception that Assad is on
the opposite side as Isis they are part
of the same side that's the truth you
hear you hear Assad saying that he's
attacking Isis that's not true he's
attacking civilians and that's what you
saw with these chemical weapons attacks
now I agree with you it's the wildering
and I've said this already but it's but
will during that we have a president who
was opposed to opposing Assad at one
point and then 24 hours later he's
bombing him that's that's that's that's
incredible
but but but they are on opposite sides
come on no they really aren't any really
so if we if we had bomb instead of
bombing that airfield which by the way
is up and working today yeah if we had
done if we had bombed the presidential
palace in Damascus because he's such a
horrible person who killed beautiful
babies that we had to actually take him
out that would not be good for Isis well
look it's just more complicated than
that bill but you really if you if
you're buying into this idea that
they're on opposing sides you're really
you're buying into Assad's and Putin
rhetoric it's just not true it's just
not true any expert will tell you it is
true it just interest rivets they're
fighting a 10 but it's not that
complicated
Assad what desaad did was horrific would
he use a chemical weapon yes but the
Constitution does not allow the
president ID States to engage in
unilateral acts of war without
congressional approval Congress never
authorized him let's not forget Obama
begged him to do it when they say Obama
did nothing about the chemical weapons
Obama did something he went to Congress
when he said give me the authorization
and they went like Obama try to follow
the Constitution right which font did
yesterday was illegal you can't just
fire cruise missiles into a country
that's not attacked the u.s. without
congressional authorization I said he
was up a real doing situation in every
which way that Donald Trump changed his
position should not be bewildered
the man has had more positions in the
kamasutra on just about everything or to
wake up today and hear folks like John
McCain like a Lindsey Graham like an
ever McMullen like a Navarro actually be
in agreement with what he did it's even
more confusing for those that supported
him because he said he wasn't going to
do it now look when he was campaigning I
thought he was a racist misogynist lying
Pig I feel he is a racist misogynist
lying Pig but he's also my commander in
chief and he just violated Constitution
I don't think you know we can all love
it and we are a deeply divided country
over that but for too long we've been
looking the other way in the face of
genocide and there's a large part of
America that wanted action because a
large you're not working what worries me
is that you know we're in the phase now
with Donald Trump of oh what does this
button do
that's not good and also during the
campaign not just he but a lot of his
surrogates talked about you know what's
the use of having this awesome military
if we don't use it including nuclear
weapons I heard them say that what why
had move we don't use him so look right
but I think what your point about you
know what do we do with this button the
good news is that he amongst a lot of
bad people he surrounded himself with he
surrounded himself with a very good
Secretary of Defense that was
overwhelmingly confirmed by the Senate
the Democrat and Republican support and
who done it
more on Secretary of State have you seen
this Rex Tillerson guy talk about a deer
in the headlights talk about a guy who
is so sorry he took this job he's like
I didn't know I had to like talk to
people make eye contact and like explain
policies and have policy or be sick or
be or be second fiddle to want it would
be a nice title secretary killers or be
or listen or be second fiddle to
secretary of everything Jared Kushner
right
right for real fixing Iraq no
fixing maybe Middle East he's skiing in
Aspen he's reinventing government and
he's going to galas with Ivanka at the
same time holla so let me ask our
liberal here on the panel how does the
fact that he went up against Russia
Donald Trump fit into the Republican of
the liberal idea that he was installed
by Putin as a stooge to do whatever
Putin wanted this is not what Putin
wanted if you're facing possible
collusion with Putin you might just want
to distract people it might be we don't
know I've learned in our project Donald
Trump right but in this case what he did
was not only unconstitutional there's no
strategy we don't know what we're doing
in Syria how long I'm going to be there
he's got us ground forces there now
they're more at risk of being attacked
right is he just attacked Assad he has
to tell the American people what we're
doing in Syria he has not done that well
I mean his tweets before this Syria is
not our problem this isn't 2013 stay out
of Syria do not attack Syria President
Obama do not attack Syria to our foolish
leader do not attack Syria do if you do
many very bad things will happen that's
right he should follow his own advice
okay